underneath this heading which is an
unexpected quadrilateral property what
I'd like you to do this is actually
harder than it sounds I want you to draw
for me a quadrilateral that is not a
special quadrilateral so I don't want a
parallelogram I don't want to square I
don't want to kite I want something that
looks really random and arbitrary which
is you can see the one that I've drawn
here but I want you to draw something
that looks a bit unusual and the reason
why I'm asking you to draw something
unusual is because
you probably have sitting in the back of
your mind this knowledge that special
quadrilaterals like let's use a rhombus
for example right special quadrilaterals
like a rhombus have special properties
right not only are all the sides equal
and rhombus like that's what makes a
rhombus a rhombus but if you were to
draw a rhombus the diagonals are always
perpendicular with each other did you
know that right um you you can't not
draw a rhombus or you can't draw a
rhombus where it's per which wears
diagonals are at different angles you
won't end up having a rhombus and every
every shape has its own different things
right like a parallelogram the diagonals
will always bisect each other and on and
on and on right so special properties
okay
now if you draw a random quadrilateral
you kind of would expect that it doesn't
have any special properties except for
the fact that the angles add up to 360
degrees because you know there's a
couple of triangles that you can fit in
there however
um we're going to explore an unexpected
quadrilateral property today and we're
going to prove that it's true using
vectors and that's really what this idea
is about in the syllabus it is can you
prove things like we used to use um like
prove that things are congruent two
triangles are congruent right so that's
a geometry proof a deductive geometry
proof we're going to do two deductive
geometry proofs today and they're both
going to be using Vector thinking okay
have you drawn a quadrilateral for me
yet yeah amazing okay now what I'd like
you to do is and if you've got another
color here this will help but you don't
have to it's just a bonus I want you to
Mark in and if you've got a do you have
a rule of there by any chance yeah
excellent okay you can do this even more
accurately than I can can you mark in
the midpoint of each of the four sides
okay so measure it out make it nice and
accurate I'm going to eyeball it here
because I don't have a ruler that I can
put over the top of my iPad that I'm
drawing on so I'm going to go this one's
pretty easy to spot
that one's going to be about there
let's see about here
and then that looks about right okay
fantastic now those four midpoints right
we can think of them as the four
vertices of a new quadrilateral and in
fact what I'd love you to do is to join
up the four midpoints that you just
created so I don't know if this is going
to work let's oh I missed there we go
let's see if this will snap for me nope
it's not I'm just gonna have to do it
like that do one more there or like so
now I wonder if if you've drawn your new
quadrilateral here in the middle have
you noticed anything unusual about yours
and mine what what have you noticed
about it
parallelogram it is indeed a
parallelogram and it doesn't just look
like a parallelogram I really like
sometimes I get the chance to do this
with a lot of different students at the
same time like there's just you and me
doing this at the moment right but no
matter what quadrilateral you try and
you can even draw like really weirdo
ones right like say for example most
people don't think of this when they
think of a quadrilateral but it is it's
still four-sided right and you can
really quickly eyeball where the
midpoints are going to be somewhere like
there there uh where's this one going to
be there and then maybe here even
without me joining them up you can
probably see oh there's a there's a
parallelogram hiding there right and
you've got yours you can draw as many as
you like and it's just kind of like what
is going on here okay there's a bit of a
mystery
so how would you go about proving that
if you draw any quadrilateral at all you
will always when you join up the
midpoints or the sides you always end up
with a parallelogram it's kind of wild
right do you have any thoughts what
would you do
um
like
um Vector of all four vectors no matter
what they are they're midpoints
uh I'd probably say that there are at
least like because I can see that two of
the sides uh like if you split in two
triangles they're like
um midpoints become too parallel sides
through that the I don't know maybe
yeah yeah okay look Sean you're doing
you're doing so well can I say you're
doing like a hundred times better than I
did when I first encountered this
problem because
um Vector thinking as you you've
probably like over the last few weeks
you've probably started to experience
it's a bit different to like geometry
thinking or other kinds of thinking and
you've got to be quite comfortable it's
like speaking a new language you've
already got the skeleton of the proof um
and so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to help you to see what's going on here
um so that you can you can prove and
it's one of the things that's delightful
about this is one of the reasons why
I've given this example is that it's
very little uh working there's not much
to write at all in fact I'm looking at
my working here there's like three lines
that's it that's the whole proof there's
a bit of drawing but the drawing is the
fun part usually what is tiresome and
frustrating about geometry proofs is you
like writing for pages and pages and
it's like oh man when am I done and the
reasoning is very long so what I want to
do with you is we're going to think of
this in Vector terms and you will see
how powerful Vector
logic is in in constructing this proof
it's very efficient okay so here's what
we're going to do I want you to think
about these four sides one two three
four the four sides of the original
quadrilateral let's just um let's get
this one out I'll just Chuck them over
here okay we don't need it I want you to
think of the four sides of this original
quadrilateral as four vectors okay now
remember vectors are Direction and
magnitude Direction and magnitude now
with the magnitude good morning Mrs Oz
by the way nice to you to join us online
and with magnitude that's just the
length of each side right so you can't
change that but with the vectors for
these sides you can actually choose
which direction you want to go right so
for example if you have a look at this
this top one up here that's quite long
right you can imagine it as starting
from the left and going to the right
that's one vector or the same side you
can think of it as going the other way
right so it's two different vectors that
we can use so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to choose directions for the
vectors that are very deliberate which
you might think why am I why am I doing
it that way and you're going to see as
we go through this why it is that this
makes so much sense okay so let's call
the top Vector a right and let's say
let's go from left to right just because
you know that's a bit easier to read
okay so you can see I've just put it's
quite small there but I've put that
Arrow there at that um top right corner
so that Vector a starts over here if you
want you could give this coordinate a
name you can call that the origin if you
like but it doesn't matter
start from o and then head over here
let's call that Vector a okay now going
from that top right corner if I put
another Vector here let's call this one
vector B so this is uh going here and
progressing along so you said vector
addition before so if I go a plus b I
end up on this this end here right
opposite to O
now you might think a natural way to do
this normally when we name things we'd
go like oh A B C D and you go like
clockwise or anti-clockwise or whatever
I'm going to do something a little
different I'm going to go back over to
the origin here
and I'm going to make this Vector down
the bottom I'm also going to go from
left to right so I'm going to call this
one I've Got A and B let's call this
bottom one C
and then lastly to round things off I'll
have Vector D and it's also sort of
going from left to right as it were so I
went from o over here that makes me C
and then up here I'm going to have this
one as d
okay are you following so far so far so
good okay now think about this right
vectors are I keep saying it because so
foundation and so important Vector is a
direction and magnitude okay so when we
say the midpoint of a side what does
that mean in terms of a vector what are
you thinking
very good so what a midpoint does is it
breaks let's think about say Vector a
right
um what a midpoint does is it breaks up
a into two equal vectors right so
there's this one over here and then
there's this other one on the other side
right now they both share the same
direction as the original Vector but
what's different
very good so the magnitudes have changed
and all we need to do is multiply by the
appropriate scalar because it's the
midpoint what's the scalar I should
multiply by uh-huh very good so both of
these vectors up the top are half a you
following
yeah okay fantastic I can kind of see
what you're gonna do yeah yeah yeah very
good okay so the logic's starting to to
sort of form in your mind right so um
actually what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to make these orange because
I realized I am um I'm starting to
confuse some of the things here so make
that one orange and make this one orange
as well okay
so you can see if we look up the top
here right see how I've got half a going
in this direction can you see I have
another Vector beside it over here yeah
you see this is the addition you're
talking about before right so this
Vector in here what's that
yeah very good so this one here half b
okay
now what this tells me is if you just
look up in this little this triangle up
the top here right the the side of this
parallelogram that you made is the same
as going half a and then half B if you
added those vectors together right so
therefore I can just call that top side
of the parallelogram half a
plus half b
does this make sense
yeah now what's brilliant is I can use
this same logic on the other side of my
quadrilateral right you're spotting it
so I want you to tell me where where
should I be looking what what vectors
should I be highlighting
um you should be highlighting the
second half day very good
fantastic so the second half of C is
down here just like I had the second
half of
um a and then the first half of D that's
actually a very clever way to say it by
the way because there's a beginning and
there's an end obviously that's oops not
a highlighter that's half d right there
so therefore what I've got now is the
half C plus half D Vector which is the
other side of what I know or what I can
see is a parallelogram
so you've done all of the drawing this
is the fun part I love this there's so
much
um logic that's just going to happen in
a very Convent condensed place right I
can say hold on a second starting from
the origin when you do a plus b where do
you end up
over at this this spot here right
um I guess I could call that P for point
right so a plus b gets you to P but
that's not the only way to this point
right what's the other vectors I can add
C plus d also get you from the origin to
P so I can say hey but a plus b and c
plus d they get you to the same spot so
they are equal vectors so therefore this
is mind-blowing how much logic is
happening here when you just treat this
with like arithmetic I can just multiply
both sides by half
and this gives me sorry I need a bracket
there
this gives me the half C plus half D and
the half a plus half B that you could
see up above and because they're vectors
right what this tells you is number one
sorry I keep saying it but Direction
the directions equal which means in like
deductive geometry language the
directions being equal means they are
parallel right but that's not the only
thing what's the other thing that's
equal between these two vectors not just
Direction
the magnitude so therefore they're not
only parallel they are equal in length
so I can say
therefore uh what do we say number one
uh oh sorry I I should put some names on
this right um so let's call this I don't
know
um what letters haven't I used yet I've
got o and I've got P let's call this
capital a
Capital Bay Capital C capital D that
said it corresponds to all the little
letters right so therefore a b is
parallel to CD because the directions
are equal and
um I guess we would say you know the
magnitude
of c a b and c d is also equal and
that's it that's that's all there is to
it
um a b in this case I've got the letter
of the order of letters is DC is a
parallelogram because opposite sides
are both parallel
and equal
stop I just love it it's like one of the
shortest geometry proofs in the world
but it's this very unexpected result and
vectors are really doing all the work
does that make sense